-Every morning when we come in,
we start our day
with a production meeting,
and that is a rundown
of what will be happening on
the show that night.
And, as usual,
one of my writers, Mike,
completely derailed
that meeting.
Take a look.
-Yeah, I thought that desk piece
turned out great, Amber.
So, we got
a very busy day today.
Let's try to run through this
as quickly as possible.
Mike, I'm specifically
talking to you.
Please no interruptions
today, all right?
-Thank you very much.
-So, for guests tonight,
we got Jeff Goldblum.
And then we'll talk
to Dick Cavett.
And, in Act 6, we are going to
do a cooking segment.
-Oh, also, my cousin "Skiz"
is on the show.
-What?
-Yeah.
He's gonna do vape tricks.
Mike, you can't just
book guests on the show
without telling anyone.
-I did tell you.
-I would never have
agreed to that.
-On Monday, I said,
"My cousin Skiz is coming
to the show this week,"
and you said,
"That's awesome, Mike."
And I specifically remember,
because up until then,
you've never said, "This is
awesome, Mike" about anything.
-I thought you meant
he was coming to watch.
-Oh. He wouldn't do that.
He hates this show.
Oh, that reminds me -- no
Trump jokes today.
Skiz is a fan.
-Are you serious?
-Well, not of his politics.
He just thinks
he's a good husband.
-You invited a Trump fan on this
show to do vape tricks?
-The man gave me
a kidney, Reece.
-He did?
-Yeah.
But I didn't even ask for it.
He just showed up one day
with an Igloo cooler
and asked me to stash it.
-How do you
get to work every day?
Does an adult drop you off?
-No, a child drives me.
I'm sorry.
Did that sound sarcastic?
I meant, no.
A child drives me.
-Well, Mike, we can't have
a four guests on the show.
I'm sorry.
-Well, then one of us is gonna
have to deliver the bad news.
-You! You're the only one
who knows him.
-I don't know Jeff Goldblum.
-We're not bumping
Jeff Goldblum.
-Aww! Poor Dick Cavett.
-I have a question.
-Yes, Skiz is circumcised.
-That is not even in
the ballpark of my question.
What vape tricks does
this boy actually know?
-Currently, none, but he said
he would learn some by tonight.
-He doesn't even know
any vape tricks?
-Uh, neither does Jeff Goldblum,
and you still booked him.
God, what is his problem today?
-When I first met you,
I assumed this was
some sort of Batkid scenario,
but it's been a few years now,
and you're still here.
-Okay. I know I don't
speak up much here.
-Oh, my God.
It's literally
the only thing you do here.
-But I'm feeling
very attacked right now,
when I did absolutely
nothing wrong.
-You booked your cousin
on the show
without telling anyone to
perform a skill he doesn't have.
[ Knock on door ]
-Hey, I'm looking for the
dressing room and also ecstasy.
-You must be Skiz.
-No.
I work for Dick Cavett.
And, for the record,
he prefers powder to pills.
-That's very cool.
-Well, tell Dick Cavett
we don't have any of that stuff.
-Wow. Okay.
He's going to freak.
-I accept your apology.